I use a lot of towels and what I will do
he's a single swipe like get out of the
shower one pass away another one
exactly yeah burn the towel he has to
buy them in bulk from Costco each week
you know yeah so
where's the bed outside because you get
like a washcloth and you get like a hand
towel and then you take those towel
that's what the robe is for and then I I
will I will fold up those like in a nice
little like hobos bag kind of thing so
that and I would I will put those into
the tub so they walk in they don't just
like gather up all these things it's
just literally just grab these and I I
saw them they do this with the sheets
they take them and they bundle up and
they they kind of do a loose tie and I
was like oh I'm gonna do that for them
and so then we get there they're like oh
this is great this guy just didn't leave
all of the time it's like 10 kilos
because of the amount of towels that you
use so nobody can lift it pretty heavy
for them
all of them
in the shower while the shower is still
going you're reminding me of an old uh
it's not getting dry